utiliza la herramienta rotar para
encontrar la imagen del pentágono c d e
f g
si este pentágono irregular que tenemos
aquí que es el c d e f g cuando se rota
270 grados alrededor del punto menos 23
la dirección de una rotación con un
ángulo positivo es en sentido contrario
de las manecillas del reloj
es decir en este sentido bien entonces
vamos a traer la herramienta rotar a
esta mejor la pantalla aquí tenemos el
botón que trae la herramienta rotar y lo
primero que tengo que hacer es dar la
posición del punto menos 23 el punto
menos 23 es este que está aquí en menos
2 en el horizontal y luego 3 en el
vertical 123 muy bien ya tengo el punto
menos 23 alrededor de donde vamos a
rotar esta figura tengo que hacerlo 270
grados a ver vamos con cuidado entonces
utilizando estas flechas que están aquí
me va a permitir hacer la rotación
entonces veamos cómo sería primero en 90
grados a ver lo voy a hacer para que se
pueda ver
si yo pongo ahí tengo los primeros 90
grados
muy bien después si me voy a esta
posición si sigo rotando
ahora tengo 180 grados y para llegar a
270 tendría que ir a esta rotación que
está aquí por ejemplo y hagamos 360 para
que regrese a su posición original eso
ya lo vimos 270 son 90 antes que 360 que
es este ángulo que tengo aquí
comprobemos nuestra respuesta
muy bien